remember when uh uh uh fauci mocked you
for talking about hurt immunity yeah i
don't know if you remember that he
mocked you for it and then he claimed
that we needed 70 percent for her
immunity and uh you know now we're with
old people
but do you do you remember that when he
mocked you i try to forget democracy but
here's what i would say is it's
important for people to try to get their
news and we can talk about things on
here hopefully that aren't being talked
about here's another one if you look on
the official websites of the incidence
of the disease by state and the death
rate
something extraordinary happened in new
york and i think it does have to do with
herd immunity if you look at the death
rate in new york it's been on the x-axis
for a year or more they had that huge
spike you know when cuomo tried to kill
everybody in the nursing homes right but
this huge spike
a lot of new york got this there were
parts of new york 30 or 40 percent of
new york may have gotten it my guess is
it may be what we should be doing are
antibody studies to see how many people
have had